die Chinesen sind deswegen heute so groß
in der Solarindustrie weil unter anderem
sie den die Maschinen dafür verkauft
haben um das zu machen das ist ein Grund
kann man das so sagen das kann man so
sagen also die das chinesische
solarwirtschaftswunder basiert bis heute
drauf haben wir das gemacht auf
europäischer Technologie aber der
eigentliche Hauptgrund warum das so
stark geworden ist ist einfach die
industriepolitische Ambition Chinas wo
eben seit 15 Jahren mit massiver
staatlicher Unterstützung mit 100
Milliarden die dort reingesteckt wurden
sind an Staatsgeld bis heute diese
Industrie aufgebaut wurde aber wir haben
den die Maschinen gekauft wir haben sie
quasi erst der tüchtigt um das zu machen
absolut richtig das ist bis heute also
wenn Sie wenn Sie sich mit dem letzten
schreien China beschäftigen was an
Technologie hingeht das ist eine
Technologie die nennt sich Topcon die
wurde 2013 vom Fraunhofer Isa in
Freiburg im Breisgau entwickelt dagegen
Maschinen bezahlt haben die Chinesen und
das reicht ihnen dann ja das reicht mir
das ist das ja das ist Welthandel ja
davon verstehe sie schon die profitieren
davon der Unterschied am Ende haben
beide davon
mehr Wohlstand erzielt das ist doch
Problem Geschichte
und sagt wir sind zurück in Europa und
Deutschland und jetzt wollen wir Geld
das geht natürlich nicht die können
natürlich nicht erst die Chinesen
ertüchtigen die Kanälen zu bauen und
sich dann hinstellen sagen guck mal wir
sind die einzigen in Deutschland die das
können
heute wenn es China nicht gegeben hätte
es wäre eine kleine Firma heute unsere
ganze Automobilindustrie hat doch diese
Transformation jetzt nur geschafft
eigentlich über China und den Welthandel
das ist eine Transformation zur
Elektromobilität zum Beispiel oder dass
sie überhaupt so gewachsen sind
riesige wachsen sind in den letzten
Jahren
sind ja die Chinesen diejenigen die hier
den Markt zu Elektromobilität aufrollen
bei VW ist eben zum Beispiel nicht
geschafft hat Kleinwagen und Mittelwagen
E-Mobilität anzubieten
der Zahl dazu der Marktanteil von VW bei
Autos in China 2,4 %. ich würde nicht
sagen dass das eine genaue Information
ist VW ist nach wie vor was die
Produktionszahlen betrifft der größte
automobilwirtschaftliche
Rahmenbedingungen Transformation ist
eben kein Erfolg
was die Transformation in China betrifft
natürlich also ich sag mal wir haben
doch davon profitiert das China sich
wirtschaftlich entwickelt hat deshalb
ist VW heute was sie Absatzzahlen
betrifft der größte Automobilhersteller
der Welt okay ja lass uns mal und davon
sind doch
hunderttausende von Arbeitsplätzen in
Deutschland abhängig dass das
funktioniert hat das
kann man auch anders sehen aber
natürlich
Argument dass wir Maschinen geliefert
haben China produziert die Module die
Betonung liegt auf haben denn China
macht das mittlerweile selbst
auf Basis europäischer Technologie und
es gibt ein absolutes
unverhältnis zwischen maschinenlieferung
und dem was man mit Modulen an Geld
verdienen kann bzw ein Umsetzen
generieren kann das ein Faktor von 20 da
drin aber das noch gar nicht das
Hauptargument das Hauptargument warum
das ein Problem ist liegt darin warum
China das überhaupt getan hat weil die
Solarenergie wie wir wissen
mit Abstand die bedeutendste
Elektroenergie Erzeugung der Zukunft
sein wird und genau aus dem Grund hat
China mit einer großartigen
industriepolitischen Ambitionen diese
Industrie in Gänze ins Land gezogen und
aber wir sind heute abhängig davon
das alles auch richtig aber ist ja mal
niemand hat sie gezwungen ihre Maschine
zu liefern sie hatten die auch nach
Italien verkaufen können oder nach
Amerika sie haben es nach China gemacht
Unternehmer haben ja auch eine
Gewinnerzielungsabsicht das heißt wenn
das ist doch ein Absatzmarkt gibt dann
liefert es runterladen aber das ist ja
erstmal gut und richtig was wogegen ich
mich wäre ist dass da hier immer gleich
so eine so eine riesen
Verschwörungsgeschichte daraus gemacht
wird bei allerschwimmung hatte keiner
was gesagt ist die man gegenüber China
haben muss hat das dazu geführt dass er
Wohlstand auf der Welt in der ganzen
Südostasien enorm zugenommen hat und der
auslöser waren die Tigerstaaten war
China und die ganzen Länder Südostasien
haben dazu beigetragen das
Arbeitsvertrag in Deutschland gesichert
wurden aber auch fordert wurden und
gleichzeitig das in diesen Ländern eben
Menschen aus Peters der Armut
herausgekommen sind und das soll das
positiv ist der dem würde ja keiner
widersprechen
ganz grundsätzlich
also sie sagen das doch gut die
Unternehmen und werfen in Erfurt vor
dass er die Maschinen nach China
verkauft hat also nicht eher vorgeworfen
aus meiner Sicht daraus keine ich hätte
keine keine Geschichte erzählen eine
Motto das das hat negative Wirkungen ja
ich meine finde schon das ist negative
Wirkung hat wir haben hier in diesem
Bereich wie viele Arbeitsplätze haben
wir da Solarindustrie verloren 120.000
so die sind einfach weg und heute sind
wir in der Situation ich habe die
Geschichte auch nachgelesen ist schon
sehr interessant sie haben angefangen
diese Maschinen zu verkaufen dann haben
die Chinesen schlechte Imitate davon
gebaut die wollte keiner haben und heute
sind sie so gut dass sie die besseren
Maschinenhersteller als wir selber
also mindestens ist das ist das ganze
System in China mit Maschinenbau mit
Material mit Materialien die man braucht
extrem weit entwickelt hat es richtig
gut gemacht muss man ganz klar sagen und
dahinter Hintergrund warum die das gut
gemacht haben ist eine
industriepolitische Ambition weil vor 15
Jahren das Thema für wichtig gefunden
hat über das wir heute in Europa noch
ganz kurz also die Chinesen haben ja
auch sehr harte Ansagen gemacht und da
kommt jetzt die Politik ins Spiel Herr
Scheffler und deswegen finde ich kann
man nicht einfach sagen das war jetzt
einfach nur die die Marktwirtschaft die
hat das so geregelt ich meine was dort
über viele Jahrzehnte ja passiert ist
und bis heute eine deutsche Firma
könnten sie in China einfach eine Firma
aufmachen Meyer Burger ganz unabhängig
so wie sie nein schwierig geht sicher
also ganz unabhängig geht gar nicht aber
sie hätten doch mindestens im
Aufsichtsrat hätten sie die
entsprechenden Leute sitzen also ich
habe dieser Tage einen
Wirtschaftsjournalisten gehört der sagte
was dort passiert ist über die letzten
15 20 Jahre ist staatlich organisierter
Technologie Diebstahl so hat es
ausgedrückt ja das Problem ist nicht die
Subventionen die die natürlich gezahlt
haben das Problem ist das Spiel falsch
ja genau die lassen keine ausländischen
Firmen in dem Maße rein äh die sind ja
Spionage verdächtig was der
Verfassungsschutzbericht heute wieder
gezeigt hat und das ist das Problem
nicht das Geld ist das Problem und
deshalb will ich noch mal aufhören
Erfurt gerne zurückkommen darauf dass er
eben nicht ableiten dass er jetzt hier
auch in Deutschland 3 Milliarden vom
Steuerzahler haben möchte damit er da
ähm gleiche Spielbedingungen hat das
geht nicht diese Subventionen
Lindner drei Milliarden Euro gefordert
zum Aufbau und Rettung des Standortes
werden seine Gebäude sie haben glaube
ich schon andere Gebäude in Aussicht
irgendwohin sie sonst verlagern würden
und kurz erklärt wird nichts zu tun muss
aber lass uns gleich darüber sprechen
noch mal kurz die Frage Herr von sie
könnten in China heute Maschinen kaufen
auch das ist nicht mehr sicher denn
China hat im zum Jahresende 2020
angefangen einen eine Restriktion
mindestens mal zu benennen und zu
kommunizieren dass die Technologie die
eins von Europa nach China gegangen ist
nicht mehr exportiert worden werden darf
und warum ich sag's noch mal weil man
die wichtigste energieerzeugungsform der
Zukunft die Solarenergie dominieren will
diese diese Geschichte auf diese gerade
anspielen das war so eine kleine
Randnotiz ne glaube ich irgendwo in eine
Ministerium nicht weiter beachtet aber
in Wahrheit nee echte Granate richtig
und das sozusagen wir haben jetzt
Maschine entwickelt auf der Basis eurer
Technologie wir haben sie besser gemacht
da ist ja auch dieser unglaubliche
chinesische Fleisch das muss man auch
immer muss man respektvoll sagen und
haben jetzt richtig was daraus gemacht
haben offensichtlich erkannt dass das
die Technologie der Zukunft ist
jetzt sind wir angewiesen sowohl auf die
Paneele die wir hier gerade sehen als
auch auf die Maschinen und von den
Maschinen sind sich die Chinesen selber
nicht mehr so ganz sicher ob sie uns die
in Zukunft noch verkaufen wollen das ist
absolut korrekt ich nenne es maximale
Abhängigkeit und das zielt das zielt auf
die Initiative hin die es eben außerhalb
Europas gibt das heißt indien hat vor
fünf Jahren Größenordnung verstanden
dass diese Abhängigkeit nicht gut ist
und hat eigene Programme aufgelegt und
fördert jetzt faktisch Produkte mit
lokalem Anteil und eine eigene
Wertschöpfung und das prominente
Beispiel sind die Vereinigten Staaten
mit dem Inflation Act der ja nicht nur
Geld zur Verfügung stellt wenn man sich
ansiedelt und eine Industrie wieder
aufbaut sondern dass der zweite Punkt
der vielleicht gar nicht so in der
Öffentlichkeit bekannt ist ist auch ein
marktschutz wir haben schon über China
angesprochen Produkte kommen die USA
nicht rein es gibt Anforderungen an die
Produkte und es gibt immer mehr
Intensivierung dass man letztlich mit
lokalen Content mit lokalen Anteil
Produktionsanteil Produkte in den USA
wir haben sie zwei Dinge erstens einen
marktschutz in einem Markt in dem
Abhängigkeiten geschaffen werden so und
gleichzeitig perfekte Rahmenbedingungen
um zu wachsen und das ist faktisch der
Kern des Puders weswegen wir auch in die
Öffentlichkeit gegangen sind im übrigen
nicht mit einer Drohung sondern
interpretiert
realpolitischer oder real
industriepolitischer Gegebenheiten auf
diese Weise das ist keine Drogen wenn
man sagt pass auf Lindner entweder gibst
du mir drei Milliarden ansonsten wandern
wir nach wohin ab wo wollen sie hin in
die USA in die USA okay das ist keine
Drogen es ist noch mal ist das eher mafi
kannst wir können ja unsere unsere
Meinungen haben zu dieser zu dieser
Industrie in unserem kleinen in
Deutschland und in Europa ich sage
einfach was hier weltweit gerade
passiert es hat Abhängigkeiten gegeben
von Gas da haben wir uns irgendwie
rausgefunden zum Glück und haben
hinterher festgestellt hätten wir es
bloß mal nicht getan und Wahlbereich
führen wir eine Diskussion als wären das
ganz normale Produkte die man ohne
Probleme kaufen kann wo es nie eine
Restriktion gibt und sehen
strategischen planen China hier wirklich
muss man wirklich braberufen mit mit
einer ganz hohen industriepolitischen
Ambitionen durchgesetzt hat bevor wir
gleich gemeinsam
ein paar Tage dabei sagen muss man wie
konnte uns das eigentlich passieren
wieso haben wir das so laufen lassen ich
halte diese These ehrlich gesagt für
völlig falsch also
wir industriepolitisch irgendwelche
Dinge vorgehen müssen und die Industrie
von morgen kennen das kennt keinen
Menschen was in 10 20 Jahren
gebraucht wird ja also sein zumindest
kein Wirtschaftsminister sondern auch
kein Bundeskanzler was wir natürlich
machen
wir müssen natürlich für
Rechtssicherheit auf der Welt sorgen
also was Patentschutz das
Wettbewerbsregeln betrifft da gibt es
die WTO die Welt Trade Organisation ja
die muss diese Regeln machen und das ist
auch die Organisation
ja und aber die muss wieder in Gang
gesetzt werden da braucht es leider
schon seit über 20 Jahren drehe das ist
ja zurzeit blockiert durch die
Amerikaner ist das blockiert worden da
gibt es keinen Gericht mehr das
entscheiden kann weil die Amerikaner die
Finanzierung blockiert haben und die
Richter blockiert haben das muss wieder
in Gang kommen aber jetzt zu sagen wir
shoppen uns jetzt ab oder wir lassen wir
bauen nur noch unser eigenes Zeug also
dann katapultieren wir uns das letzte
Jahrhundert vor das letzte Jahrhundert
also ich sag mal die Erfolgsgeschichte
ist doch dass wir Handeltreiben dass wir
uns austauschen und das Länder auch
strategische Entscheidungen mit
berücksichtigen ist richtig ist richtig
aber da müssen wir halt auch aber wir
halten nicht ja aber wir haben
vielleicht einen anderen weil sie am
Anfang über über Moral und Werte
gesprochen haben wir haben einen anderen
Ansatz wir sagen wir setzen auf den
einzelnen auf das Individuum auf die
Unternehmer die Dinge entwickeln ja da
gibt es keinen Zentralrat der
entscheidet jetzt investieren mein
Solarzellen sondern bei uns entscheidet
das Unternehmen im Einzelnen gerade wenn
wir das so machen würden dann schießen
wir uns selber zurück ins letzte
Jahrhundert das Argument verstehe ich
nicht ja weil ich sag mal wenn wir alles
selbst hier in Deutschland produzieren
würden dann wäre so teuer dass es im
Zweifel keiner kaufen würde so einfach
sie sie glauben nicht dass sie sie
deuteten gerade an wer weiß was in zehn
Jahren ist vielleicht ist der photovolta
kein Thema mehr sie können heute gar
nicht wissen ja aber ob jetzt die
Photovoltaik-Anlage die er heute baut ob
die in 20 Jahren noch Stand der Technik
ist wissen ja gar nicht ob das das
Unternehmen ist die sind sehr innovativ
ich habe mir im vorfeldformiert hoher
Wirkungsgrad ja aber ob sich das ob sie
diesen innovationsniveau fortführen
können auf Dauer weiß ich nicht ja das
wird der Wettbewerb entscheiden sie in
der Vergangenheit mal über solche Themen
die Frage ob man irgendwann sagen muss
okay auch wenn das die die klassische
FDP-Position ist das macht irgendwie der
Markt
mal darüber nachgedacht überlegt was
sozusagen die Division ist was die
Zukunft ist und ob man das wirklich so
machen kann auch wenn man dann sieht die
Chinesen haben glaube ich 50 Milliarden
nee in ihre Solarindustrie investiert in
den letzten noch mehr noch mehr noch
mehr jetzt kommen die Amerikaner mit dem
österreichischen Staatsgeld die
Unternehmen natürlich genau
das heißt setzt man da immer mal
zusammen und überlegt irgendwas was ich
25 15 2 14 uns überlegt was ist
eigentlich der Weg wo geht die Reise hin
gibt es solche Momente haben ja jetzt
durch die Pandemie und auch durch den
Ukraine Krieg er hat durchaus eine
Bewusstseinsveränderung ja weil die
einzelnen Abhängigkeit von einem Land
ist vielleicht nicht so gut ja ist aber
bei Russland erlebt das erleben wir
jetzt auch bei China ja aber die was
machen die Unternehmen solchen Fällen ja
sie versuchen ihre Lieferketten zu
differenzieren ja und ihre Strategie zu
ändern ja und wenn sie es nicht tun dann
laufen sie eben Gefahr wie in Russland
oder wie in China irgendwann mal durch
irgendeine politische Entscheidung
hinweggefegt zu werden das heißt ist im
unternehmerischen Interesse zu
differenzieren und das wird werden die
Unternehmen auch tun also diese diese
grüne Revolution die da gerade
tatsächlich weltweit auch wirklich
gestaltet wird sie haben sich dazu mal
eingelassen finde das ganz interessant
schon paar Jahre her sie sich
was sie meint sie werden Kollegen und
haben eine interessante Einlassung von
ihnen gefunden was ich auch in der Regie
das gerade vorliegt aber vielleicht kann
man das mal zuspielen bitte schön
wir haben in verschiedenen Fragen Reden
und Handeln nicht zusammengebracht wir
haben auch als FDP die Energiewende in
Deutschland aktiv mit angestoßen also
die Abschaffung der Atomkraftwerke von
heute auf morgen
die Einleitung einer Energiewende die
eigentlich ja planwirtschaftlichen
Grundsätzen folgt und weniger
marktwirtschaftlichen Grundsätzen das
führt dazu dass die Energiepreise in
Deutschland steigen durch die starke
Förderung erneuerbarer Energien und das
macht die deutsche Wirtschaft
Wettbewerbs weniger wettbewerbsfähig und
das wird unterm Strich eben dazu dass
mittelbar auch Arbeitsplätze gefährdet
werden auch das passt eben zu einer
liberalen zu einer Partei die
Marktwirtschaft die das rechtschätzt
eben nicht dazu
interessant
aber dann guter Beitrag
sie sind sie treu geblieben könnte man
sagen sie treu geblieben naja der Platz
stieg war 2013 ein Fehler und das für
die Kernkraftwerke jetzt
abgeschaltet haben war auch ein Fehler
ja aber
Frau Hönig warum haben sie gerade so
gelacht oder sich amüsiert nicht gedacht
wurde zu sagen Philipp Rösler war ja
damals sehr Bundeswirtschaftsminister
und der ist ja am Ende der Totengräber
der deutschen Solarindustrie gewesen aus
berechtigten Gründen wir erinnern uns
vielleicht als Verbraucher daran das war
die Zeit als solardachbesitzer 50 Cent
pro Kilowattstunde Einspeisevergütung
bekommen haben 50 Cent heute kriegt man
wenn man Balkon äh Kraftwerk hat oder
auf dem Dach im 18 von seinem Stadtwerke
und 18 und die Verbraucher mussten es
damals mit einer irre hohen EEG-Umlage
zahlen die war ja ein Problem für die
Bürger und die ähm Industrie jetzt wurde
sehr endlich endgültig abgeschafft aber
viele Grüße hat damals eben als
Bundeswirtschaftsminister vor eine
Vollbremsung gegeben und hat bin 4
Wochen wurde die Förderung dramatisch
gekettet und wenn
ist das natürlich extrem schwierig da
hatten an der Industrie dann doch
ziemlich den Satz ich habe immer das
Problem wenn man mit Subventionen
versucht eine Industrie hochzufahren
wenn man das dann abbauen will dann ist
der Schmerz immer besonders groß frage
ich mich warum ihr Finanzminister einer
10 Milliarden Euro Subvention für Intel
naja es war erstmal der der Ball lag auf
dem Elfmeter den Medien vernommen habe
war Christoph Christian Linda dagegen
zwar am Ende die Entscheidung des
Wirtschaftsministers das zu machen dass
wir hier wird natürlich auf dem Geld als
Finanzminister hat er immer das letzte
Wort kommt
zumindest nicht aus dem Kernhaushalt des
Haushaltes ja sondern es wird richtig
sagen zu können wir waren es nicht ja
aber es war am Ende nicht die
politischen Entscheidung von Christian
Lindner sondern das wollte er weg wollte
diese 10 Milliarden Christian Lindner
wollte sie nicht nee da wollte sie nicht
feiert sie wollen sie auch nicht ich
will sie auch nicht aber
das ist am Ende Regierungshandeln das
auszureichen ich halte auch für falsch
ehrlich gesagt also 10 Milliarden ist
unheimlich viel Geld ja richtig also ich
will das mal sagen wir investieren pro
Jahr in die Schiene eine Bedarfsplan
Schiene 2 Milliarden und da wird für ein
Unternehmen zehn Milliarden ausgegeben
wir waren schon mal besser bei der
Schiene bin ich jetzt wir haben die die
Investition für die für einen Schienen
Bedarfsplan war noch nie so hoch in den
letzten 15 Jahren aber ja lustig das
jetzt ein FTP Vertreter zum Bahn ich
will das nur sagen ja viel über hat
nicht so
ja aber doch
auf jedenfall machen ich halte das für
einen großen dann Killer kommt halt
nicht nee dann müssen sie ich meine wir
halten
den Wettlauf der Subventionen
internation Kanal nicht aus die
Amerikaner oder die Chinesen die sind im
Zweifel immer besser okay
Industrien zu pimpern ja das halte ich
für völlig falsch am Ende bezahlt die
Übersetzung für letztes Arbeitsplätze
wir haben in Deutschland faktisch voll
beschäftigen faktisch Vollbeschäftigung
wir haben ein Fachkräftemangel in
Deutschland
das was jetzt an 10 Milliarden bezahlt
werden muss der Zahlen doch Unternehmen
in Deutschland der Handwerker der muss
das bezahlen ja und warum ich will nur
sagen was die Konsequenz ist also die
Konsequenz wäre dann Intel würde nicht
kommen und der Erfurt würde mit seiner
Firma endgültig nach Amerika gehen ja
ist das ist das dass wir Kondition also
sie würden sagen
ein Problem haben was unseren Standort
betrifft das ist keine Frage ja also
dass wir zu hohe
ja Bürokratie Steuerlast haben und so
weiter dass wir zu langsam sind im
Planungsbereich das haben wir jetzt das
Planen zu Beschleunigungsgesetz das ist
völlig klar aber ich meine wir müssen an
die Ursache gehen und nicht versuchen
dagegen anzusubventionieren das ist halt
man nicht durch Frau Robert sie die sie
auch Unternehmerin sind wie schauen sie
da drauf wie diskutieren Sie dass ich
höre dass sie regelmäßig Joe fix beim
Vizekanzler haben ist richtig richtig
wir treffen uns in jeder Sitzungswoche
wir sind ja auch im Wahlkreis ab und zu
und Robert habe das ist ja miteinander
dass genau
Milliarden kriegen und sollte Intel
seine 10 Milliarden kriegen Frage wir
müssen uns doch mal ehrlich machen als
Land was ist wie wollen wir die
Wirtschaft in Zukunft hier haben und das
ist nicht pampern sondern wir wollen ja
mal auf dem weißen Blatt Papier sein was
sind denn die Zukunftsfelder das ist
Wasserstoff das ist die Chip Industrie
weil ohne den Chip fährt kein Tesla
fährt kein E-Auto und da gibt's kein
Windrad zeigen
da haben sie recht Grüße nach
Niedersachsen so also wir haben wir
müssen uns doch mal ehrlich machen
welche Industrien wir hier in Europa in
Deutschland stark in der Zukunft auch
brauchen und deswegen finde ich das sehr
richtig weil Intel sagt ja nicht 10
Milliarden und das ist irgendwie unsere
Kondition sondern die bringen ja auch
was mit nämlich 20 und das ist die
größte Investition in der deutschen
Geschichte aus dem Ausland je nach
Marzahn und damit entsteht eben also
nicht gute Matte aber das genau also das
ist ja nicht so schwer gegeben es ist
auch nehmen und noch mehr mit dem was
drumherum entsteht Zuliefer und wir sind
ja da auch total abhängig also wir haben
ja gelernt aus der solarindustries
Situation die wir ja jetzt hier noch mal
schön miteinander rekonstriert haben
dass wir nie wieder weil die ganzen
Chips kommen nämlich auch aus Taiwan die
kommen aus China die kommen aus Korea
und wir müssen ja da auch eine gewisse
Unabhängigkeit schaffen und deswegen
diesen Plan was wir in der Zukunft haben
und was wir hier ansiedeln wollen das
muss eben aktive Industriepolitik
leisten und für die besteht eine
sozialdemokratische Fraktion im
Deutschen Bundestag
das ist der verräterische Satz wir
müssen einen Plan haben nein der Staat
muss keinen Plan
was der Staat weiß was die Mode von in
zehn Jahren ist haben wir in der DDR
erlebt als er aussehen
Politik
und wenn die Solarzellen nicht aus
Deutschland kommen weil es sich hier äh
nicht lohnt weil es hier für ein
Unternehmen nicht attraktiv ist dann ist
das kein Problem dann heißt
Diversifizierung wir sollen nicht alle
ähm Solarzellen aus China kaufen genau
den Fehler sollen wir nicht wiederholen
wie wir es in der Gaskrise gemacht haben
aber wir müssen nicht die Solarzellen in
Deutschland produzieren wichtig ist dass
wir verschiedene Quellen haben und
dieser Subventionswettlauf wohin soll
das führen jetzt sagt Maja Burger ich
geh weg wenn ihr mir nicht was gibt sagt
das nächste Woche auch wenn ich nicht
die
zweite Stahl ne eine Anlage bezahlt der
Stadt denen die brauchen aber vier
unbedingt genau da reden wir über wie
viel Geld zwei Milliarden kriegt
ThyssenKrupp jetzt um ein Hochofen
umzurüsten zu einer klimafreundlichen
Direktor
für fürs Protokoll den den Hochofen den
Stahl mit grünem Wasserstoff
herzustellen genau
und wird da wird mit Hilfe von
Kohlenstoff der Sauerstoff rausgezogen
so dass wir roh Eisen haben und die
Zukunft ist dass wir mit Hilfe von
grünem Wasserstoff den Sauerstoff
rausziehen bekommen eine tolle
Technologie aber ThyssenKrupp kriegt
baut jetzt eine Anlage die brauchen aber
vier um den Standort Duisburg auf dem
gleichen Niveau zu halten und wohin soll
das führen wollen
das ist wirtschaftlich funktioniert kann
grünen Stahl und damit sind wir
Vorreiter ohne stark kein Windrad und
ich will da jetzt nicht sagen tschüss
ihr Lieben wir lassen jetzt all das mal
sein also wir machen jetzt keinen Stahl
mehr die Grundstoffindustrie ist auch
egal Chemie brauchen wir nicht was
bleibt denn dann kann doch sich nicht
erpressen lassen der kann
jetzt Schule macht dann geht doch jeder
Konzern in Deutschland hin der
irgendeine Investition haben möchte und
schreibt Christian Lindner am Brief und
sagt entweder du gibst mir ein Drittel
dazu so einfach gelernt haben also ja im
Ruhrgebiet das Beispiel von Nokia vor
vielen Jahren ja wo die mit viel
Subventionen nach Bochum gelockt wurden
und als sie also weg war aus lief sind
sie nach Bulgarien oder Rumänien
gegangen also ich meine das ist keine
nachhaltige Wirtschaftspolitik sondern
nachhaltig ist wenn man die die die die
Grundlagen setzt damit Unternehmen
freiwillig sich hier entwickeln und
nicht über Subventionen aber die
Konkurrenz schläft natürlich nicht es
gibt den den Arsch also den den
Inflation redakt ist auch interessant
heißt Inflation redakt also es geht um
offiziellen Reduzierung von Inflation da
geht's ja um alles aber nur nicht um das
Reduzieren von Inflation
viel Geld genau aber gemacht wenn man so
will
was würde das Erfurt für Sie bedeuten um
das mal zu verstehen also was ist für
Sie so interessant daran ähm in die USA
zu gehen jetzt zum jetzigen Zeitpunkt
vielleicht noch mal grundsätzlich wir
erpressen niemand das machen wir nicht
wir drohen auch niemanden
mit einem Weckruf darauf hin was auf
dieser Erde gerade passiert das eine
dauersumventionierung in der Wirtschaft
keine nachhaltige Lösung sein kann wenn
die ganz breit erfolgt völlig davor das
ist sicher auch nicht für einen
europäischen Unternehmen das Instrument
ist dass man anwenden sollte auch davor
aber zum einen findet auf dieser Erde
gerade ein eine industrielle Revolution
statt nämlich eine grüne Revolution es
wird sich so viel verändern es werden
sich Antriebe verändern es wird sich
energetische Grundlagen verändern und
darauf stellt sich die weltindustrie ein
china hat es schon vor einer ganzen
Weile erkannt das habe ich schon erklärt
die Amerikaner haben verstanden dass sie
wenn sie damit spielen wollen
auch ein Instrument brauchen das ist der
URL der am übrigen zu massiven
Investitionen führt also wir haben in
den Brief geschrieben dass wir schon
Gebäude haben ja
Formulierung
läuft und Europa kann sich jetzt und
Deutschland gerne noch zwei drei Jahre
unterhalten ob das ein gutes Tool ist
oder nicht es wird einfach dazu führen
dass diese Transformation der Wirtschaft
und diese neue industrielle Revolution
woanders stattfindet und deswegen halte
ich die Diskussion für mindestens ein
bisschen naiv und ich finde sie auch ein
bisschen doppelt zügig denn wir tun ja
gerade so oder
an als hätte es in Deutschland nie
irgendwie Subventionen gegeben was ist
denn der Kohlepfennig gewesen das sind
Subventionen gewesen
also das passt doch überhaupt nicht
zusammen
kein Problem wenn die wenn Sie die
Solarzellen nicht in Deutschland
produzieren machen sich woanders und wir
kaufen die dann gerne auch wenn sie ihn
in den USA die ähm
Entschuldigung
wie viele Arbeitsplätze hängen denn da
dran bitte also
sie produzieren in Sachsen-Anhalt wir
produzieren in Sachsen-Anhalt
1000 Mitarbeiter wie viel 1000 1000 und
die die sind auch nicht gefährdet denn
wir haben bestandslinien es geht
grundsätzlich darum wie wir weiter
investieren machen wir das hier oder
machen wir das in den USA sie wollen sie
wollen wie viel Gigabyte produzieren sie
Moment wir haben eine nominalkapazität
von 1,4 GB das 1,4 das klingt sehr viel
ist aber im Weltmaßstab noch sehr klein
und der größte chinesische Hersteller
macht 45 kann das sein viel mehr in
Richtung 80 Gigabyte genau ich habe
gelesen die machen 45 und wollen auf 90
hochkalieren genau
einer und da gibt es mindestens acht
große genau sonst kommen immer wieder
neue dazu aber zu Ihrer Frage zurück was
passiert in den USA wenn wir dorthin
kommen zum einen gibt es über den ARD
hinaus noch weitere
Instrumente die die USA anwenden es gibt
also auf
Staatsebene und bundesstaatsstaatenebene
teilweise auf
stadttebene wo man sich niederlässt noch
mal eine Förderung bares Geld es gibt
ein ein Darlehensprogramm des Department
of Energy wo man Zins vergünstigte
Darlehen erhält und dann gibt es den ARD
alleine bedeutet dass man pro Gigawatt
Produktion pro Jahr 110 Millionen
US-Dollar erhält als Solarhersteller der
Solarzellen und Solarmodule produziert
das wäre in unserem Fall so dass wir
zwei Gigawatt aufbauen würden wir haben
einen solarmodulwerk in USA schon in der
Entstehung und es geht jetzt das ist in
der Nähe von Phoenix das wird gerade
gebaut das ist auch bekannt und jetzt
geht es darum wird die Solarzelle die
dazugehört auch dort gebaut warum weil
vor ca 4 Wochen die US-Steuerbehörde Ars
eine Entscheidung bekannt gegeben hat
dass man für einen weiteren Text credit
eine Steuergutschrift auf Ebene der
Installateure die Solarparks
Installation installieren noch mal eine
Gutschrift bekommt wenn die Solarzellen
den USA gefertigt sind damit garantiert
zwangsarbeitsfrei aus Silizium das in
der Regel aus Deutschland kommt von
Wacker bzw aus den USA um faktisch
ein lieferkettengesetz ein Stück weit
mit Gewalt durchzudrücken und jetzt
geht's darum eben zu entscheiden für uns
bauen wir die Solarzelle auch da drüben
auf und dann sind wir bei zwei Gigabyte
und das sind dann zwei Mal 110 Millionen
220 Millionen das kriegen sie fünf Jahre
bis 2029 in Gänze das sind 1,1
Milliarden und ab 2030 31 32 geht es so
ein bisschen runter 33 ist es perfekt
mal kurz anrufen
natürlich kann man jetzt mit
Protektionismus oder mit staatlicher
Förderung irgendwie versuchen Industrie
anzulocken aber historischer das noch
nie richtig geklappt ich glaube nämlich
dass was nicht gesehen wird ist dass das
was in Amerika gemacht wird ja von den
Amerikanern irgendwie auch bezahlt
werden muss also das was da investiert
wird kann ich an anderer Stelle
investiert werden ja irgendeiner das
Geld ist ja nur einmal da also
irgendeiner muss es ja bezahlen und ähm
hier entscheidet der Staat dass er
gewisse Industrien fördern will aber
andere die vielleicht nicht im Fokus der
Politik sind die gehen dann leer aus die
müssen sogar bezahlen
ja und Unternehmer leuchtende Augen
kriegen wenn Sie diese ganzen Programme
aufzählen wo sie von wem welches Geld
abgreifen dann macht mir das Angst ja
wenn wir das Übertragen auf Deutschland
müssen wir ja auch sehen dass fällt
nicht vom Himmel das Geld sondern dass
er Wirtschaften die Verkäuferin bei
Karstadt und das erwirtschaftet der
Handwerker über seine Steuern und die
sollen diesen ganzen Subventionswettlauf
bezahlen der am Ende zu nichts führen
wird außer dass die Unternehmen die
Staaten gegeneinander ausspielen das
werden wir sehen ob das zu nichts führen
wird die Zunahme Investitionen in
industrieproduktionen in den USA ist auf
einem Höchstniveau im Vergleich zu den
vergangenen Jahren und dieses Modell
über diese Steuergutschriften den USA
führt dazu dass eine Industrie die sonst
ja gar nicht entstehen würde entsteht es
ist das Programm woher wissen sie das
woher wissen sie dass diese Industrien
dann nicht entstehen würden in Europa in
Amerika
sie wird entstehen habe ich gesagt ja
nur die würden entstehen durch diese
Situation entsteht im Bereich der
Solarenergie und in den in den
Erneuerbaren energienbereichen nicht
ohne diese internetsion weil China
andere Rahmenbedingungen entsetzt ja da
müssen wir über die Rahmenbedingungen
reden aber nicht über das Geld sie
können gerne immer über Spielregeln
geistigen Eigentum alles
dann wäre die Logik die die herr Schäfer
schon gesagt hat dann müsste jemand den
Mut haben zur WTO zu gehen und dafür zu
sorgen dass es nirgendwo auf der Welt
Solar Subventionen gibt ja gewissen
Regeln
also die
stimmte Arten von Hilfen sind erlaubt
aber man darf es nicht übertreiben und
das ist auch richtig
in einer Dimension das ist unvorstellbar
übrigens auch mehr Geld als der
Inflation
kompliziert deswegen kurze Frage zum
Schluss noch Erfurt sie sagen ah
Genehmigungsverfahren in den USA es geht
wahnsinnig schnell wie schnell haben Sie
Ihre Genehmigung um eine Fertigung
hochzuziehen wie lange dauert sowas
dauert das dauert weniger Wochen das
geht wirklich Wochen
zwei Jahre
fast zwei Jahre also so 21 Monate ist
jetzt zum Beispiel aus letzter Woche was
mir zugeht
dann kann man dann auch noch mal warten
schnell kommt dann ist erstmal das dann
hat die EU sich das angeguckt und das
Projekt ist notifiziert also genehmigt
und das dauert dann auch noch bis das
Geld kommt also es ist wahnsinnig
komplex die ganzen Nachweispflichten
danach also das ist absolut viel zu
träge für eine Welt die sich schneller
dreht also das neue Deutschland Tempo
von dem machen okay ich verstehe okay
und die zweite Frage verdienen Sie Geld
herfotieren in Deutschland läuft das
profitabel für sie läuft gerade gut wir
sind wir sind ja im Aufbau planmäßig
beim vor drei Jahren angefangen übrigens
nur privates Kapital aufgenommen eine
Milliarde ohne Staatshilfe also das ist
normale wichtige eine wichtige
Klarstellung und sind gerade im Aufbau
und dem Hochlauf und beabsichtigen dann
mit in der entsprechenden
helfen letzte Frage zum Thema Subvention
dieser industriestrompreis ist ja auch
heute Thema gewesen da würde uns
tatsächlich weniger helfen werden
natürlich schön etwas weniger kostet
weil wir nicht so viel Energie
verbrauchen aber die Grundstoffindustrie
ist ja enorm
energiestrompreis glaube ich nicht dass
man in Europa
langfristig diese diese Produkte
produzieren kann weil in China dieser
Strom auch subventioniert wird und in
den USA auch das sind immer wieder bei
dem gleichen Themen und jetzt Frage an
Sie der nächste Regierung produziert
industriestrompreis
haben
um 2000 Unternehmen Chemieunternehmen
und auch Maschinenbauer zu
subventionieren und 38.000
Industrieunternehmen sollen nichts
bekommen deshalb haben die
Familienunternehmer passiert
hier sitzen sozusagen sitzen zwei
Drittel der Ampel und beide sagen sofort
nein nein nein nein nein nein also das
wird nicht kommen aber aus dem grünen
Wirtschaftsministerium hören wir das
Ding wird wahrscheinlich kommen ist doch
der bleibt
so wie Sie es gerade beschrieben haben
wird es nicht kommen weil es gibt ja
noch kein fertiges Konzept und deswegen
sind wir ja noch mitten in der Beratung
weil ich bin nämlich auch dafür dass wir
niemanden also dass wir es nicht zu eng
fassen und die Familienunternehmen
natürlich jetzt nicht leer ausgehen
sondern wir müssen uns überlegen wen
wollen wir denn helfen aber sie wollen
dass die Subvention kommt der
industriestrompreis eine temporäre
Brücke denn das Problem ist ja wir sind
jetzt an dem Punkt wo die Kosten sehr
hoch sind und wir müssen die Brücke
bauen bis wir dann mal die Erneuerbaren
günstig und gut und viel verfügbar haben
und deswegen temporär als Brücken und
sie herr Schäffler sind ich halte das
für eine falsche Weise ja weil ich
glaube
da zweimal das Pferd von der falschen
Seite auf wir müssen gucken dass wir
insgesamt für alle Bürger die auch
Strompreise reduzieren die Stromsteuer
weiß beispielsweise sen und nicht oder
mehr angebotschaften zum Beispiel wir
haben ja selbst ein Stück weiter zu
beigetragen dadurch dass wir jetzt sechs
Kernkraftwerke in Deutschland
abgeschafft haben das hat auch dazu
geführt dass der Druck auf der
Angebotsseite zugenommen hat und die
Preise insofern auch hoch sind und da
sollten wir eher schauen dass wir dafür
sorgen dass wir hier mehr Angebot machen
Wochenende
6 Cent hat der Arbeit ja angeboten dann
sagt der vci-chef er hätte lieber vier
Cent ja ähm oder vielleicht umsonst
genau lieber drei und gibt
der deutschen Unternehmen die ist
beängstigend und da müssen wir von
zurückkommen wir brauchen keinen
industriestrompreis lassen Sie uns doch
die Stromsteuer für alle senken auf der
Handwerker was davon
ausführlicher und und ausgiebiger noch
dis